legendary computer scientist Alan Kaye
once said the best way to predict the
future is to invent it I love this quote
because as developers we have the
incredible privilege of building the
future for Humanity but based on the way
things went in 2022 I think we must have
done something wrong because 2022 has
been a messed up year and there's
probably more pain to come first Russia
and Ukraine went to war then all the
high-flying tech stocks declined like 90
Bitcoin dropped from 69 to 16k while
simultaneously gas and food doubled in
price Zuckerberg Zuckerberg the
metaverse while Elon destroyed free
speech by allowing people to speak
freely but most shocking of all I found
out my 100 Natty Fitness coach the liver
King is actually juice to the gills yes
I'm on steroids apparently if nothing is
what it seems in today's video we'll
look at 10 Trends affecting software
development and technology that you can
capitalize on in 2023. let's kick things
off by talking about tech jobs all the
big Tech corporations have either had
hiring slowdowns hiring freezes or mass
layoffs if you're learning to code or
look looking for a job these headlines
can be pretty scary now while the job
market for software Engineers has
definitely softened there's a few things
to keep in mind here first when there's
massive layoffs like this the vast
majority of jobs have nothing to do with
software engineering Engineers are still
extremely valuable and most of those
that were laid off were able to quickly
find employment elsewhere second outside
of fang the job market still seems to be
pretty strong it's by no means Frozen up
and there are still tons of job openings
out there especially at non-tech
companies that have struggled to
modernize the bad news is that interest
rates are still high and will likely
remain high at least until 2024 that
means less easy money for startups to
over hire there's still a labor shortage
in Tech and if that ever changes Look
Out Below because that means the greater
economy is likely going straight to hell
now speaking of jobs back in 2020 I
talked about the work from home Trend I
thought that Trend would be more
permanent but it appears to be making a
reversal because managers often hate it
like they get frustrated when their
employees are secretly working six
full-time jobs at the same time Snapchat
recently called its workers back to the
office and I think we'll see more
companies do this to implement soft
layoffs where they simply get rid of all
the people who don't want to come back
to the office as Elon said they can
pretend to work somewhere else but now
let's switch gears to crypto in 2022 we
saw the Pawn's eenomics of the crypto
World exposed there was collapse after
collapse with people's life savings
being wiped out in the process this
creates a contagion effect where people
no longer have enough money to spend
millions of dollars on pictures of
monkeys during all this chaos hashtag
web 3 went missing if you see it
anywhere please contact the local
authorities while there is a lot of cool
stuff going on in the crypto space a lot
of it feels like vaporware and even
though it's been around for over a
decade now it still has yet to disrupt
centralized Computing in any meaningful
way the so-called decentralized web 3
companies often rely on centralized
services from AWS and gcp that basically
tells you everything you need to know
the hype train has derailed but that's a
good thing if you're betting long term
on crypto because there's a lot of
scammers and criminals that need to be
weeded out speaking of derailed we
should also talk about the metaverse
Zuckerberg changed the name of Facebook
and poured billions of dollars into this
project but the only good thing about it
is all the Dank memes making fun of it
in my opinion the metaverse is something
that sounds good on the surface like
flying cars but actually kind of sucks
in reality humans already spend way too
much time staring at screens and the
idea of strapping a screen to your face
to block out this entire shitty world to
escape to an even shittier world is just
an absurd idea now the metaverse is not
just Facebook there's also decentral
land whose Mana token is down 90 and a
bunch of other companies investing into
their own metaverses like crypto there
will be opportunities in this space
however I don't think we'll ever see a
day when everyone is walking down the
street with one of these things strapped
to their head it'll be more of a niche
market for gamers and masturbaters now
at this point this video has been pretty
negative but things are about to get
worse because AI got so much better in
2022 it's now possible for AI to
generate art using tools like Dolly 2
and stable diffusion Google came out
with dream Fusion 3D which can generate
3D models from a text prompt just
imagine how much easier that could make
the development of 3D games than meta
came out with make a video which takes a
text prompt and generates a video you've
got voice cloning that's now almost
indistinguishable from the real thing
like this podcast between Joe Rogan and
Steve Jobs you're a memory from the past
good to see you buddy it's been a long
time since I've been on the show and
over the past week the world has been
going crazy over chat GPT which is smart
enough to do your algebra homework write
poetry for your wife and fix your broken
code stack Overflow even took steps to
ban it because people are using it to
post answers about stuff they know
nothing about but now I want to take a
180 and talk about front-end web
development one of the most noticeable
Trends is the willingness of developers
to move away from react and try out
newer Frameworks like spelled solid and
quick react is still the status quo but
there's been a lot of little trauma
surrounding it the Shopify drops server
components from its framework and took
the remix approach but most importantly
there's just really appealing
Alternatives nowadays that offer 0js by
default and better performance cleaner
apis and things like that and there's
new JavaScript Frameworks coming out
every single day pushing the limits of
what's possible speaking of which I
would highly recommend anyone watching
this video to take the state of JS
survey it provides a ton of insight into
the front end world and the more people
that vote the better and for the first
time ever fireship made the cut as an
option on the survey in addition to
these new Frameworks reaching maturity
I'd say Technologies like tailwind and
typescript will remain very strong in
2023. in addition I think Veet will
continue to take over as the default
build tool for most projects aldoever
sells turbo pack which is a rust-based
build tool that has made some bold
claims about performance has the
potential to do great things in 2023 but
build tools are boring one of my
favorite things about being a web
developer is watching the evolution of
design Trends over time like we went
from no design to geocities to way too
much complexity and then finally to
minimal flat designs which most websites
still use today to figure out the
hottest design trend of 2023 I reached
out to Gary Simon from design course the
hot new trend we're seeing is
neo-brutalism where you have vibrant
colors high contrast strokes and
cartoon-like Graphics I think it
provides a very nice aesthetic but it's
the kind of design I'll probably be very
sick of by the end of 2023 when every
other website is using it now when it
comes to front-end web development
another big trend is the death of the
single page application nowadays there's
a strong preference among Developers for
server-side rendering by default that
means react developers are using
Frameworks like nexjs view developers
are using nux felt developers are using
svelte kit and so on one of the main
drivers of this trend is cheap
serverless cloud computing in addition
to High Performance Edge Computing it's
incredibly easy to deploy serverless
functions on versel netlify and Firebase
and it's just easier for developers to
build full stack applications when both
client-side and server-side code is
handled by a unified framework in
addition developers in 2023 place a much
higher value on type safety across the
entire stack most of these Frameworks
offer end-to-end type safety and there
are tools like trpc that make it much
easier to implement end-to-end type
safety anywhere now speaking of the back
end we've seen a ton of innovation
around databases in the last year I feel
like almost every week I'm getting hyped
up about a database I've never heard of
before which I like to call New Wave
databases they're Cloud native or
serverless and usually combine multiple
database paradigms usually some
combination of relational graph and
document we have tools like surreal DB
Edge DB fauna and Zeta all of which have
very Innovative new ideas about how a
database should work then we have other
companies taking a more traditional
approach like Planet scale and Cockroach
serverless to make the gold standard
relational databases easier to work with
in the cloud you've also got popular
databases like neo4j and mongodb
offering serverless options as well now
I'm going to make a video comparing all
these databases in the near future so
make sure you are subscribed to the
channel another thing we need to talk
about on the back end is this idea that
people desperately want to get away from
languages like C plus in 2022 Google
announced carbon but it's years away
from being production ready the dominant
new systems language in 2023 is clearly
rust maybe not in total adoption but
definitely in the mind share of newer
developers not only is it loved by
developers and being used in a lot of of
modern systems but just a few months ago
it was officially added to the Linux
kernel that means future updates to the
Linux kernel can be written in Rust now
I realize that most of us here are far
too dumb to ever even think about
contributing to the Linux kernel but the
fact that Linus Torvalds is welcoming
rust into the ecosystem says a lot about
the language's future and that gives us
10 Trends to watch out for in 2023 even
though 2022 sucked it was only a test
the fact that you made it this far in
the video means that you passed the test
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one